et on termine avec cette manifestation
virtuelle prévue aujourd'hui en soutien
à julian assange détenu à londres depuis
avril 2019 le fondateur de wikileaks a
vu sa demande de libération sous caution
refusé il ya plus de deux semaines
le point avec mehdi est ce que fit
confiné mais pas résignés les défilés
dans la rue rendue impossible à cause de
l'épidémie les défenseurs de la liberté
d'expression organise une manifestation
virtuelle pour soutenir julian assange
ce samedi l'initiative prévoit le
partage de bagnères virtuelles envoyées
sur les réseaux sociaux les
organisateurs particulièrement remontés
par les récents événements concernant le
fondateur de wikileaks au début du mois
le royaume uni a annoncé la libération
de 4000 détenus afin d'enrayer la
propagation du coronavirus susceptibles
d'être concernés par cette mesure
exceptionnelle en raison de son état de
santé
julian assange est finalement resté en
prison au grand désarroi des militants
il poursuit sa peine dans
l'établissement de haute sécurité de
belmarsh louis pinto l'un des plus
importants lanceur d'alert de notre
temps qui a révélé les magouilles de
ronaldo mendes les contrats de milliers
de joueurs de football et la réalité de
certains des systèmes les plus corrompus
qu'ils soient vient de sortir de prison
à caen assange
le 25 mars dernier julian assange avait
demandé une libération conditionnelle en
raison de la pandémie de kovy 19 une
requête refusée par la justice alors que
ses avocats estimaient que leur client
était fortement susceptibles d'attraper
le virus selon la bbc
l'épidémie aurait tué près d'une dizaine
de prisonniers au royaume uni dont un
dans la prison de belmarsh prochaine
étape pour julian assange le 18 mai date
de l'audience concernant sa possible
extradition vers les etats-unis mais ce
rendez vous pourrait bien être
repoussées en raison de la crise
sanitaire